le 1er mai c'est une tradition on offre
un brin de muguet à l'élu de son coeur
ça porte bonheur à l'origine ce geste
est davantage censée déclencher les
sentiments chez celles qui reçoit les
fleurs plutôt que dévoiler ce de celui
qui les offres j'adore ce parfum ses
frais on se croirait à la campagne au
beau milieu de la verdure une vraie
capsule 2d confiné et il faut en
profiter car ce parfum est insaisissable
le muguet ne produit en effet ni essence
ni absolue pour fabriquer cette note les
parfumeurs doivent avoir recours à
d'autres senteurs dans leur jargon
ils disent que le muguet est une fleur
met un comble pour une plante qui est
couverte de clochettes qui je vais
l'offrir tient la petite caméra
si vous avez aimé cette vidéo n'hésitez
pas à laisser un pouce bleus vous pouvez
également voir ou revoir celle des jours
précédents il suffit de cliquer sur le
côté gauche
je réalise une nouvelle chaque jour
alors pour être sûr d'en louper aucune
et bien abonnez vous et activer la
clochette à demain et n'oubliez pas nous
sommes confinés
mais on reste en lien